so we cast it again as a machine
learning problem but we had multiple
models interacting and tuning each model
separately was a complete nightmare and
during that process I decided surely
somebody must have thought about
something and you know that but the
problem is that a lot of the state of
the art was working only for tuning a
few hyper parameters at the time what
we're trying to do was really tune
thousands you're listening to the
Microsoft Research podcast a show that
brings you closer to the cutting edge of
technology research and the scientists
behind it
I'm your host Gretchen heusinger you may
have heard the phrase necessity is the
mother of invention but for dr. nicolò
phousi a researcher at the Microsoft
Research Lab in Cambridge Massachusetts
the mother of his invention wasn't so
much necessity as it was boredom the
special machine learning boredom of
manually fine-tuning models and hyper
parameters that can eat up tons of human
and computational resources but bring no
guarantee of a good result
his solution automate machine learning
with a meta model that figures out what
other models are doing and then predicts
how they'll work on a given data set on
today's podcast dr. Fuji gives us an
inside look at automated machine
learning Microsoft's version of the
industry's Auto ml technology and shares
the story of how an idea he had while
working on a gene editing problem with
Chris Burke as 9 turned into a bit of a
machine learning side quest and
ultimately a surprisingly useful
instantiation of automated machine
learning now a feature of Azure machine
learning that reduces dependence on
intuition and take some of the tedium
out of data science at the same time
that and much more on this episode of
the Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
Niccolo phousi welcome to the podcast
thank you it's great to be here so you
lead the automated machine learning
efforts at Microsoft Research in
Cambridge Massachusetts I really want to
wade into the technical weeds with you
in a bit
but for right now in broad strokes tell
us about your work what gets you up in
the morning yeah it's interesting
because my background is machine
learning and I got very excited about
problems in computational biology and so
I did a lot of working operational
biology and then during that work I kind
of figured oh there are so many machine
learning problems that you can solve
that are interesting and applied to a
wide range of things and so it kind of
went back a little bit in machine
learning so most recently as you said
I'm working on automated machine
learning which is a field where the goal
is to kind of automate as much of the
machine learning process as possible
that goes from data preparation to model
criticism for instance once you come up
with the model so drilling a little bit
on this idea of computational biology so
computational biology is an enormous
field there are many kind of different
people doing different things from
proteomics to genomics some of them are
using mathematical tools some of them
are more probabilistic or statistical in
nature so my slice of this word was
using machine learning and statistics to
kind of investigate molecular mechanism
and in particular I was working on
genetics mostly I also worked on
functional genomics but genetics was the
most formative part of my training
so we talked a little bit about your
interest in machine learning
computational biology and medicine in
fact yeah so those are three sort of
divergent paths well there's some
overlaps on Venn diagram but how did
those all come together for you
I started in machine learning and you
know machine learning you can do either
applied work you pick a problem you
apply machine learning to it it always
comes with its own set of challenges or
you can pick something morta reticle and
maybe advance the way people do modeling
or infer the parameters of a model for
instance and when it came to starting my
PhD I had the choice of problems from
both fields and
due to personal circumstances I felt
like I needed to do something that had
an effect on human health but I also
thought that human health was too far
for machine learning and in some sense
to this day I still think that if you
want to do medicine with machine
learning I think you need to stop
somewhere in between first like and
break up your journey and I think you
probably should break up your journey at
the molecular level which is where
computational biology comes in so I
started working on solving questions in
computational biology using machine
learning with the goal of later kind of
going from computational biology to
medicine again using machine learning
that's fascinating
before we launch into your specific work
in the field let's talk a little more
generally about automated machine
learning
Forbes magazine had an article where the
author claimed that it was set to become
the future of AI is that overstatement
well in general in the eye right now
there is a lot of this is the future of
AI that is the future of action every
great as somebody who does a lot of my
research if optimal will single-handedly
the future of all of AI but I think it's
going to be a huge component and I think
more than automail it's probably going
to be meta learning if one has to put
names interesting on fields because meta
learning is learning about learning so
in some sense I think we have developed
over time a good set of kind of B's
models of based algorithms and now we
are starting to move up the hierarchy
and kind of combine classes and families
of models into metamodels yeah and that
kind of incorporate all that is going on
underneath them so in some sense I agree
with the Forbes article in a sense that
we need to move one level up the
hierarchy
yeah but there is a lot more work to be
done at the base let's drill in a little
bit on why automated machine learning is
such a big deal yes okay and perhaps by
way of comparison so you alluded earlier
to the traditional machine learning
workflow yeah tell us what that looks
like and what an automated machine
learning workflow looks like and why
it's different and why it matters in my
mind the traditional machine learning
workflow which is also the data science
workload people use different names you
start with some question and you define
what kind of data do I need to answer
that question what kind of match
measure my success and what's the
closest numerically computable metric
that I can pair and I can measure and to
see whether my model is doing well and
then there is a lot of data cleaning and
then eventually you start the modeling
phase and the modeling phase involves
transforming features changing different
models tuning different parameters and
every time you go down one path you pick
a way to transform your features you
pick one model you pick a set of
parameters and then you test it and then
you go back and you maybe try different
the part is you gather more data you
keep doing this loop over and over again
and then at the end you basically
produce one model that maybe you deploy
maybe you expect to see whether the
predictions are correct or fair or stuff
like that
the goal of automated machine learning
is to automate as much of this as
possible I don't think we'll ever be
able to automate the phrasing the
question or deciding the metric because
that's what the human should be doing
really but the goal is to kind of remove
as much of the high dimensional thinking
with many options that are not always
clear that really kind of slows down the
process for humans I've heard it
described just the dredge work of data
science the fine-tuning of the the
models and the the parameters explain
that a little bit more about how is it
basically a trial and error it is a lot
of a trial and error because it's really
high dimensional space so depending on
which value you set one hyper parameter
to yeah all the values for another hyper
parameter completely changed meaning or
change the scale at which they are
relevant and so it becomes a really
difficult problem because I've done it
right it's extremely boring not a good
use of time if you do kind of parameter
sweeps which is a lot of what the
industry is doing you cannot waste a ton
of computational resources and you have
no guarantee of finding anything good
[Laughter]
yeah so how are you tackling math so
there are different techniques and
ottomanism very exciting research area
there has been like optimal competitions
automail workshops symposiums at nips
it's really very exciting at the broad
idea is let's try to use a model to kind
of figure out what other models are
doing so in that sense is kind of meta
learning because you're trying to
predict
different models react when you change
their parameters and you use that model
to guide you through a series of
experiments all right so you would have
to have a base of model experiments for
this uber model to judge right exactly
to learn from yes from better words yes
[Music]
according to legend I use that term
loosely you were using machine learning
and getting mired in the dredge work of
data science and basically thinking
there's got to be an app for this or
something and you set out to fix the
problem for yourself it wasn't like I'm
gonna go create this Auto ml thing for
the world it's like I gotta solve my own
problem and you kind of did it covertly
tell us that story he has so I was
working on CRISPR gene editing it was a
joint collaboration between Microsoft
Research in the Broad Institute at the
Broad Institute the lead investigator
was John Dench and that Mike Rizzo
research was Jennifer Lise carton was
now at Berkeley and me and basically we
got this data we figure out the question
we did all the deciding which metric we
want to optimize and then we spent six
months maybe of our own time almost full
time trying different ways slice and
dice that model space the parameter
space it was just exhausting what
question were you trying to answer in
these work we were trying to investigate
and build a predictive model of the
target activity in CRISPR cos 9 so
CRISPR is a gene editing system it
allows you to mute the gene that you
don't want to be expressed for instance
this gene is causing a disease I want to
shut it down yeah so you can do that in
previous work we basically figured out
again a machine learning model to
predict given the many ways you can edit
the gene there because you can do it in
different ways what's the most
successful edit and in this follow-up
work we were investigating the issue of
given that I want to perform decided
what's the likely that I mess up
something else in the genome that I
didn't want to touch you can imagine if
I want to remove a gene or silence a
gene that was causing a disease I don't
want to suddenly give you a different
disease
because unintended edit happened
somewhere else and so we cast it again
as a machine learning problem but we had
multiple models interacting and tuning
each model separately was a complete
nightmare and during that process I
decided surely somebody must have
thought about something and you know
that but the promise that a lot of the
state of the art was working only for
tuning a few hyper parameters at the
time what we were trying to do was
really tune thousands right and so it
would have taken ages and so I kind of
had an idea
while working on CRISPR so it was kind
of like a side project he kind of worked
and it was suspicious because it was a
weird approach that was not supposed to
work it was really a hack and so I kind
of kept it quiet kind of use it to for
my own experiments but I didn't
advertise advertise it okay so the best
of brightest minds all over the world
are trying to tackle this problem like
you say there's other companies working
on it they've got symposiums they've got
competitions and here you are in your
lab working on a CRISPR cast nine gene
problem and you come up with this tell
us what it is so it's something that
actually is used already by you know
Netflix Amazon we probably use it
somewhere in the company to recommend
things right so the idea was ultimately
deciding which algorithm which set of a
parent receives for a given problem
you're kind of trying to recommend a
series of things and then evaluate them
and I tell you well they worked and then
you kind of update your beliefs about
what's going to work and what's not
going to work okay and that is similar
to movies right you watch a movie you
rate it and then they learn more about
you your tastes and so on the good news
for us is that we don't actually rely on
the human watching the movie we can
force the execution of a machine
learning pipeline we can just tell
execute this thing and they perform
let's say well or not so well depending
on which data set they're exposed to so
you can now gather a corpus of
experiments that help you guide the
selection of what to do in the new data
set so that's the meta learning aspect
you have these meta model that knows and
can predict our individual based models
will
or when shown some given data okay so
implementing this yeah so because I was
the first user I didn't want just
something that you could lean on
academically sure oh you know we beat
random because random is a strong
baseline for optimal surprisingly like
picking a model at random right I wanted
to encapsulate this work into something
I could use into a library right so we
worked on a first version of a toolkit
you could just deploy in your data and
we started using it for our own stuff
and then we were working on this and in
the summer at Microsoft you have the
hackathon which is this huge initiative
everybody kind of takes part and a lot
of teams were looking for that a
scientist and it was crazy because on
the machine learning mailing list was oh
I'm working on you know these
accessibility problem is there anybody
who knows machine learning who can help
me out with this data analysis question
and so we thought okay so if nobody is
responding to that email maybe we should
just blast out an email to the entire
milling list saying we have 50 spots so
we can give you an API key that we
designed in a bad way and if you want to
use something that kind of finds the
model automatically do you phrase the
question and we kind of search your
model space for you and give you a
pipeline you can use at the end just
give you a Python object you can ask for
predictions okay what was the response
the response was crazy so we were a
research team of two people and
specifically sir so we didn't have a lot
of systems on behind us so it was a
single machine serving this meta brain
model that kind of figures out what to
do and by our calculations we could only
accommodate 50 teams so we got 150
requests within you know the first week
unbelievable so we stretched our
resources a bit thin to let people use
it so you did accommodate 150 we did
accommodate the under and 50 in the end
okay it was a lot of CPU time that way
yeah and a lot of like last minute all
the services down can you reboot
something that we'd never experienced a
well ok so this is the hackathon and it
sounds to me like the scenario you're
painting is something that would help
validate your research and actually help
the people that are doing projects
within the hackathon itself it was kind
of a win-win because we saw some
real-world usage of our tool it was very
limited in being we
could only do classification not
regression problems just because we
start with that sure and people came and
they it's our single could you add this
base learner or can this pre-processing
method and it was very useful to us what
did you say no I can't answer was always
it's just you know it's just as but one
day it's just research it's just
research yes well let's go there for a
minute there's been a big announcement
yeah that's ignite very exciting can you
talk about that so yes it's very
exciting announcement he took a ton of
work from a lot of very smart people so
it's a joint collaboration at this point
between MSR you know we did the original
kind of proof of concept and a huge
amount of work went in from people
within Asher so it's being released as
kind of like a automated ml library or
SDK that you can use on your data and
it's in public preview that's super
exciting you know we have a very good
collaboration and a very good ability to
now transfer what are technically
complex ideas yeah you know this
technology transfer was not like a small
simple model that you could just write
quickly and we had to think about these
the probability distribution calibrated
are the choices that we make based on
that information correct in most cases
for most data sets what's the cost on
run time on our servers to satisfy the
demand that this thing will likely have
so it was a lot of engineering work and
I think we figured a lot of that out and
so we can able to transfer a lot of the
research into product much more quickly
well who's the customer for this right
now we struggled a little bit because in
the early validation phase let's call it
the research prototype let's give it
away phase we got a lot of different
kind of people approaching us so data
scientists they are interested in
because they want to save time they
don't care in a lot of cases what the
final model is they just want a good
model and they don't want to spend ages
just running parameter sweep so that the
scientists are one set of individuals
who could be interested developers
sometimes developers now our task with
including intelligence in their
applications and if you don't know what
to do this kind of solution gives you a
good
model in a short amount of time relative
to the size of your data so you can just
use it and then there is a lot of kind
of business analysts the buyers from
companies they have to make data-driven
decisions and they would benefit from
good predictions and this tool would
give them good predictions so going back
to your comment about data scientists
being a customer why wouldn't a data
scientist be a little bit worried that
this Auto ml might be taking over a
third of yeah I get asked that question
a lot I created for myself not intending
to replace myself but just kind of as a
tool for me to use the metaphor I use
for this it's kind of like using a word
editor doesn't replace the role have a
writer or writer it just makes the
writer that much more effective because
you don't have to cancel with a pencil
your old fax and just rewrite it from
scratch you can just erase one letter
for instance and that's what automail
does like if you change let's say the
way you feature eyes your data you don't
have to start from scratch with the
tuning you just set an optimal run going
and you just move on would it
democratize it to the point where non
data scientists could become data
scientists I think it's a possibility
because in some sense you observe this
meta model kind of reasoning about your
data and you see the thinking process if
you can call it thinking you see which
models it starts out with and then it
sees how it wolves and so you can
actually learn things about your data by
observing the process observing our
different metrics are you know sometimes
you want to maximize accuracy but maybe
looking at something like an area under
the ROC curve is informative because you
can now see how the probabilities are
changing so I think you can learn from
what ml and I think it can become kind
of like some training wheels if you're
starting out let's go back to CRISPR for
a minute since this all started with how
to make it easier to decide where to
edit a gene yeah you made a website
CRISPR dot ml that provides bio
scientists with free tools they can
choose to make CRISPR gene edits
basically yes tell us about the site why
did you start it and how is it going
that's a great question so it's crisper
dot ml that's the URL we had to really
really resist the crazy hype to not call
it crisper dot AI which was available
and we just said no it's ml it's not AI
we decided not to feed the hype around
the eye that was self restraint on
steroids I know it took a lot oh that
was so we had done work on the on target
problem which was how do you find the
optimal for some notion of optimality
how do you find the best idea to perform
to make sure that you disable a gene
that you want to disable and that was
giving you predictions it was a tool
that you could use in Python you could
just unload it from github we just gave
it away liberally licensed and so on and
a lot of startups incorporated that in
their tools selling it a lot of
institutions were using it the
off-target stuff which was how do you
make sure that you don't have unintended
edits somewhere else in the genome that
was much more computationally intensive
to run as something you could download
so if you were interested in running it
for your own problem of interest you
would have to wait a long time and so we
decided why don't we just pre compute
everything for a human genome which took
an exorbitant amount of CPU time on
Azure but we could just pre populate a
giant database table and then search it
almost instantly and that's what the
website does you can put in the gene you
want to add it and you get a list of
possible guide with a score that tells
you how likely the Edit is to be
successful and how likely each of target
is so happen to happen in a global score
that tells you broadly speaking
bad by bad of targets here don't that
don't you yeah so it both tells you
what's a good place to go and tells you
avoid these places because lots of bad
stuff could happen in some sense it
tells you which place to add it and if
you choose to add this these other spots
on the genome might be edited and maybe
you don't care so maybe your experiment
is very narrowly focused on a given
genes so maybe you don't care but in
therapeutic applications we want zero of
targets pretty much all the time yeah
yeah that leads me into a question
that I asked all of the guests on the
podcast is there anything that keeps you
up at night about yeah gene-editing
autumn L&I what can go wrong right now I
am I'm not easily kept awake night
I can sleep anywhere but you know there
are things that concern me and I tried
to move my work towards addressing them
as a first priority maybe the main thing
on my mind right now is I know that
autumn el or what we call autumn el he
is a very good way to predict so it's a
very strong supervised machine learning
method and it can be applied to all
kinds of data and I want to make sure
that as we build a capability to
generate better and better predictors we
are also thinking of ways to make sure
that the predictions are well explained
that the biases are auditable and
visible to the person who's deploying
these systems so we are spending a lot
of time now thinking how fairness and
all these themes that mention a lot in
this podcast are addressed because it's
a very powerful tool and if you apply it
in the wrong way you're going to have
exorbitant amount of bias
[Music]
tell us a bit about yourself
Niccolo what's your background how did
you get interested in what you're doing
and how did you end up at Microsoft
Research it's a good story so I I will
not start from when I was a baby I will
start directly from university I did my
University of Milan close to home well
at home basically and then I attended
some advanced courses in statistics and
I thought it was fascinating but I was
always kind of like more of a computer
science person and so I figured computer
science plus statistics at the time the
answer was machine learning I think to
this day probably there is a same answer
for most people and so I decided to kind
of do a summer internship somewhere
anybody would take me you know these
kind of ashtag rejection stories I must
have sent 30 or 40 emails so everybody
in Europe to say can you please like I
will come for free like for a summer it
was kind of like my summer vacation that
here and I think the response I got was
from Neil Lawrence who was now also a
pod castle's as part of other things
talking machines and I wrote a seemingly
broken Italian because he speaks a
little bit of Italian but he can speak
it but I cannot write it if he hears
this help is okay with that and it says
sure come over and I went there for a
summer the goal was to kind of build up
my CV to do grad school somewhere so I
wanted to do some research you know get
a feeling and after that summer I
basically decided now I'm staying here I
wanted to pitch the I'm right here I'm
coming back in four months and I
basically kind of closed up all my stuff
like finished my exams at home just like
my thesis and just packed up and went to
the UK so Neil at the choice of projects
and because I wanted to have an impact
on health I kind of chose the molecular
biology inspired projects and I started
working on that and it was one of the
best you know 3 years of my life it was
a lot of fun I learned a lot yeah and
you got your PhD I got my PhD well in
the last year I traveled a lot during my
PhD because I spent some time at Max
Planck Institute into minion I spent
some times at UCLA at these
pure and applied mathematics there was a
program where the idea I think of to
represent it correctly was to kind of
combine some mathematically minded
people and some biology / medicine
minded people to see what kind of
collaborations arise it was an
incredible program for like I think
three or four months during which I met
this group of Microsoft is in LA you
were doing statistical genomics and that
included my longtime collaborator
Jennifer this garden and I started an
internship there the year after and then
at the end of the internship they say
hey do you want to join so again once
more I went back I packed everything up
and I said sure and I joined Microsoft
Research in LA which was this remote
site it was five of us all kind of
working in else so there's not actually
a lab it was a rented office that used
to be a steak house on the UCLA campus
very very unofficial if you if you ever
been to a Microsoft building you see all
these you know machines that include
beverages like sodas and so on we are -
ever standing order from supermarkets
delivering us the sodas cuz I didn't
have a place we didn't really have
facilities it was just as in our network
was Ethernet cables running everywhere
that's hilarious did you at least have
some signage I don't think so it was
probably you know those plastic signs
that you can kind of get at any store we
had those but we didn't have a sign that
said Microsoft but we were in the
address book so sometimes Microsoft
salespeople would come to our office
intending to access the corporate
network but they didn't understand it we
were not on the corporate network even
oh you read that off turn off of the
grid listen so then how did you come to
be at Cambridge did you go straight from
LA to the Cambridge lab yes so I think
after a couple of years in LA different
people moved in different places and Jen
lease garden came to Boston and I heard
this Boston lab is incredible and so I
admits I met with Jennifer chases the
lab director I was like I need to visit
there and check it out and I joined I
think three years ago now so you moved
up all yours I moved up all myself again
I said I love it here and just moving as
we close I like to ask all my guests
to look to the future a little and it's
not like predictions of the future but
more just sort of as you look at the
landscape what are the exciting
challenges hard problems that are still
out there for young researchers who
might be yourself a few years ago trying
to decide where do I want to land where
do I want to pack all my stuff up and
move to that's a great question and when
I spend a lot of time thinking about
because we have a lot of interns the
quality of the students right now is
exceptional so even maybe a first year
PhD student has an incredible amount of
experience very often and they're asking
you a worse day in direct my career and
it's hard to give advice but I think the
area were expect the most improvement
and interesting work to be done is pride
the area of making decisions given
predictions so I think a lot of machine
learning is focused correctly so on
giving good predictions we are now kind
of topped out performance on a lot of
tasks that were considered very hard
image recognition in 2012 I think it was
or 2013 was really our task and now we
are kind of like we can achieve great
performance great top one top 5%
performance but I think the gap now is
okay we got good predictions how do we
make decisions with those predictions
and I think with that you need to have a
notion of uncertainty and while
calibrate an uncertainty so you need to
be certain the correct percentage of the
time and then uncertain the rest and you
know self-driving cars and all these
things will need the notion of raising a
red flag and saying I don't know what's
going on I need to not make a decision
right now
please intervene he need a notion of low
confidence prediction please do
something else don't use me for your
decision and beyond but but in general
there is this notion that you need
uncertainty and we are in a decent spot
for quantifying uncertainty but there is
a lot more work needs to be done to have
safe robust machine learning system so
that's a fruitful line of inquiry for
somebody who's interested in this yes I
think you know as a student you need to
kind of imagine like
skeet shooting you need to shoot the
head of your target if you are entering
the game now and you're trying to just
maximize predictive accuracy where
predictive accuracy is basically like a
root-mean-square minimizing a routine
score or maximum accuracy I think it's
about time to do machine learning if
that's your objective but I think
thinking more end-to-end that what is
the end goal of this machine learning
system is going to be a much more
interesting area in the future Niccolo
fuzzy thank you so much for joining us
today on the podcast I'm enlightened and
it was so much fun thanks for having me
it was fun to learn more about dr.
Nikola fuzzy and the latest research and
automated machine learning visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]